good morning William it's Friday March
4th one of the very few dates that's
also a sentence March 4th
today we're going to take a voyage into
the dark heart of contemporary
narcissistic megalomania by playing
Sheen or Gaddafi the rules are pretty
simple like I'm gonna tell you a series
of quotations and you're going to guess
whether that potation was set by Charlie
Sheen or Moammar Ghadafi however for the
purposes of making the game challenging
I will be translating Moammar Gadhafi's
quotations from Arabic because otherwise
it'd be really easy to figure out you
know is it in Arabic would be the
primary question you would be asking
okay let's just play your first
quotation every great movement begins
with one man and I guess that's me who
said it Sheen or Gaddafi time to guess
you just click on whoever you think said
it by the way you might want to turn on
annotations I mean if you're still
watching this video
presumably because your annotations
aren't on turn them on and then click
Sheen or Gaddafi